full up force character creator is
pretty robust but do you ever find
yourself wishing you could play as man's
best friend instead of just a man I'm
your faithful companion Tony and this is
your GameSpot news update the mod is
called be the dog and it's exactly what
it sounds like it lets you play as a
number of different dogs from the
Commonwealth but let's be honest you're
going to choose dogmeat you can't use
guns but you will be able to battle
enemies with different biting attacks
mob designer Abba loves you has a few
warnings you can't access your pip-boy
in first person when using the dog and
the whole thing might crash if you start
as a dog at the very beginning of the
game otherwise have fun speed a dog can
be downloaded from Nexus mods and it's
far from the only fallout mod out there
fallout 4 is first DLC launches this
week too so you should have no shortage
of wasteland content to explore to keep
up with all the fallout news feel free
to wander on over to GameSpot